delta ha evidenciado la brecha entre los
dos estados unidos la alta transmisión
de la variante ha provocado un rebrote
de los contagios y hospitalizaciones
principalmente entre la población no
vacunada por un lado los estadounidenses
que todavía no recibieron el fármaco son
los menores de 12 años no son elegibles
para la vacunación y están sufriendo más
esta ola
sabemos que la variante delta se propaga
rápidamente no solo entre adultos
también entre niños y adolescentes
causando la mayoría de los casos que
detectamos a día de hoy y la verdad es
que los niños de menos de 12 años
todavía no tienen acceso a la vacuna
vaccinia
de cara a la vuelta a las aulas tras las
vacaciones california ha impuesto la
vacunación obligatoria para el personal
docente de centros públicos y privados
tras aplicar la misma norma para los
trabajadores de la administración y de
la salud
en este nuevo güey que creemos que es lo
correcto y que es la manera adecuada de
mantener las escuelas abiertas y
responder a los padres preocupados como
yo que tengo cuatro hijos y eso es que
las escuelas hagan todo lo que están
manos para mantener a los niños a salvo
ahora
tickets safe
sin embargo california uno de los
territorios más progresistas del país
cuenta ya con un elevado índice de
vacunación en relación a estados
tradicionalmente republicanos la gran
división entre los estadounidenses que
decidieron recibir el fármaco y los que
no es en gran medida partidista según
una encuesta del washington post jay
vice news el 47% de los republicanos son
reticentes a la vacuna mientras que
entre los demócratas la cifra baja al 6%
la polarización política ha encontrado
un nuevo eje de articulación y ha
frustrado el plan de vacunación masiva
con el que bardem llegó a la casa blanca